ich verstehe nicht wo der 83 ok nee nee
einfach nein der ist da unten oder wobei
ich glaube dass echter und müssen wieder
runter gehen
moschitz und herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten folge der neuen ende games serie
law top ten
und wie immer werfen wir einen blick in
die stats nicht in die kids in dieses
hier platz 90 sind wir das heißt die
zweite folge muss kommen und sie kommt
ich sag's euch im spiel mit welchem kit
verspielen wir hier durch das gewünscht
ich bleibe jetzt mal die kommentare 1
und ich habe gesagt die kids die
gewünscht werden werden auch gespielt
und wir spielen heute mit dem dennis
akad rangelei hallo
bevor jetzt weiter ab spaß machen kurzen
cut und sehen uns gleichen runde wieder
bis gleich klassen der runde
more verriet wird gespielt denn es ist
dabei und windows drei eisen oder dass
mir mein halten ich glaube ich bin
unbesiegbar ich glaube dass das gericht
als bio malta da gibt's kein holz erstes
bio mahlzeiten
das heißt die barbaren dieser welt habe
jetzt den kassen vorteil
nein ich bin ja panik bekommen weil man
die switche immerhin da können wir so
ein bisschen tippen und so aber ich habe
auch eigentlich ein relativ geile idee
jetzt falls er diese wird dieses in
diesem app einfach jetzt nicht munden
sollte machen wir das einfach so ich
mache einfach so eine kleine compilation
hat sie könnte man sagen was ihr davon
haltet schreibt kommentare ich habe mich
gerade bei enni arts und video gesehen
übrigens andy hat richtig gute leute
vorher ist extrem
da habe ich ein video gesehen wo die
alle länder games zocken die machen ja
noch nicht so oft
deswegen relativ oft gefehlt haben
deswegen halt so eine compilation
gemachte zusammenschnitte und das ist
eigentlich eine richtig geile idee weil
es eigentlich mega schade ist wenn man
wegen einem tod oder so also abwägen
einem frame einer unachtsamen sekunde
dann acht unter par alles wegwerfen muss
die ganze aufnahme wer halt echt schade
und was hast du davon ja ich finde es
auch ganz kurze zeit das vorbei sagt
doch was auch pass auf ich werf 1 which
offers auf ja ist er bitte also gott du
bist ein geiler typ dass mir gerade von
equipment geklärt du bist ja ein
riesiger hengst richtige bahn
diese komischen diese komischen kühe
geben trotzdem fleisch alter ich glaube
dir geben sogar mehr vielleicht als die
anderen
das teilte einfach eben viel fleisch
gegeben gibt es ja echt überhaupt keine
keine bäume
ich glaube nicht leider ich glaube ich
nicht aber wir haben jetzt immerhin die
barbaren rüstung holzschwert läuft bei
uns jetzt brauchen wir noch bisschen
pfeile dann können wir die runde ich
auch gewinnen ist halt da hinten ist
eine strecke die ich hoffe mal dass kein
kate zu dem büro
ja er hat mir ein eisen schwer wieder in
eisenstadt hat dann gibt's halt sich
anscheinend auf holz ich haben die
erschwert
du bist noch am ohr herz in einem wetter
folglich zeit oder der hat viele
vorteile
ich hoffe wenn man gleich wie switch ok
erstmal gereckt alter ich bin mir egal
moment mal ich hab doch das kit mofa aus
gewitter wird bist du das meinst du
nicht fakt alter reden
an junge euro hier muss es doch irgendwo
holz gehen das kann nicht sein kann doch
nicht angehen warten wir mal okay 250
wirklich zuerst mal hier die ihre gäste
vom junge ich hab holz gefunden
ich habe holz gefunden solche reisen
mitnehmen ich glaube hier ist ein hacker
drin ja etwas neues ja kein ein hit born
hat doch ich war nah dran hält für ein
ja die glocke keys ich kräfte mir kurz
walter wenn jetzt nicht drauf rentner
jetzt musst du ja okay ich habe
verstanden kollege ist okay ich erst mal
ein schwert und er kommt ich weiß es
nicht es gibt so einige menschen
alles ist also die happy sailor
angreifen
solche menschen völlig aber solche
momente natürlich immer den glauben an
die menschheit dazu meinen die drei fans
endlich los
wir machen einen kurzen kuss gleich
wieder so leute dass wir wieder weg in
der runde eine andere
das geht nur mit uns ab als er gerade
eben weil er dieser nette mitspieler da
hab ich auch diesen pipa gehört habe
keine ahnung was er gemacht hat ich weiß
nicht welche funktionen erfüllt hat oder
warum er überhaupt da war ich weiß nicht
denn das kannst du dir einen draufmachen
macht es geht weiter immer noch
humorvoll und ja juli minimal
ja was denn handy halt coach herbert of
mac juni hier ist schon wieder so einer
dvd finis kacke denkst du bist ich weiß
nicht was du bist und das mir egal ich
bin tot
ich weiß nicht was du bist und das ist
mir egal
ja was ich mit dem macher wird schlimmer
als clown weißt du spaß
aber wenn dann wieder so leute kommen
einfach es muss ja das passiert glaube
ich nur die also ich hatte das noch nie
passiert aber auch gut gesteckt alter
das man wie viel glück gewann das gar
nicht wissen' vier blöcke das waren
meine fresse aber wir wissen das nicken
dann kann ich da nichts passieren außer
von verfall schaden außer wenn ihr kann
ich über hab ja genau schuhe sind
wichtig dabei aber das sei ja erst mal
diese cookies ist zur ausnahme mal nicht
denn ist okay bekommen und das sind
nicht immer getan werde ich so ein
verdammt schönes lächeln bei dem skin
habe meine mitspieler
ich will jetzt eine haut überziehen
dass dieses rätsels lösung so okay und
ich gucke immer weiter davon dass sich
da was rosa durch die büsche schimmern
gott bitte stirbt stirbt und bitte
doppeln fleisch in der zone a la nicht
den wirklich hunger verlierer ist ja
nicht geil alter
und normale leute fand ich schokolade
und chips gegessen
ich hoffe ich hoffe einfach warte ich
hoffe einfach ich habe jetzt keine
schuhe oder mutter wie money boy weißt
du kennst du deine bild von moneyball wo
einfach so bei gegessen hat und diese
extra 3 am und gelassenheit und meinte
der bau ist frei oder sowas
es gab ja ok davon kinder
es läuft bei uns ja leute so misst es
machen beziehungsweise abstauben
befürworte ich nicht allerdings in der
aufnahme ist das also meiner meinung
nach etwas anderes und ich hatte das mit
maxi schon mal gefragt also mit carney
und da war die resonanz auch so ja hier
team was aber ich komm passiert man den
tablet gemeint ja abstauben bzw team
oder teams halt nicht sogar prinzip sich
genauso aber in der aufnahme kann man
zwei machen oder kann man es machen und
das fand ich eigentlich als cool so so
sich das nämlich auch ja und für alle
schlauer merke was schlanker junger
leute sind der 4 life hinweg weekend
catch me was habe ich gerade von kit
bekommt weiß er selber den film bekommen
und wir können es einfach dem stealth
xxl wegrennen war was los sei will auf
jeden fall nicht so pralle was sagst du
hast alle feuchtesten vokabular auf
jeden fall nicht so ich habe in letzter
zeit voll oft die richtigen
wortfindungsstörungen hatte ich vorher
nie ich war immer ein richtig allocator
bastard aber in letzter zeit geht es
bergab mit mir aber auf jeden fall für
alle schlauberger schnell merker und
menschen die weizen verlieren so wie ich
ich habe wieder die alte diamant schwer
textur drin
die hat nämlich richtig gut gefallen und
dann greift der sweet boy hat mir
da gesagt ja alte textur kannst du
natürlich haben kein ding bier und ja
läuft bei ihnen auf jeden fall ihr ist
es und ich finde es sieht einfach aus
wie stich aus herr der ringe
kennt ihr das also fotos schwert das
leuchtet ja auch so blau wie knox in der
nähe sind und hier sind einfach
geradeaus in der nähe 50 bürger bis zum
nächsten ort auf junge das ist kein spaß
aber wo ist da ich glaube da ist einfach
unterirdisch mein leben jetzt schon
unsere erde die reifen service der
unterirdisch da versteh das nicht
einfach spielen unsichtbar
nee nee nee nee der ist hier muss die
unterirdisch sein weil der kompass ich
um diesen punkt tritt lonely 12 31 grad
der bald eine falle und was für eine
jo fast fast fast wäre ich rein gefallen
weil die wallonie eins zwei drei vier
leute noch aber ich wollte ich wollte
ganz schön den wasser einmal runter
packen
genau da wo ich geschwitzt aber dann
habe ich schon stillgestanden kommen die
volle entschärfen es war dann finden wir
natürlich nicht sogar ich bin ein horst
die kamera alleine
wie kann man so ein horst wie ich wollte
etwas richtigen injection über die lava
springen und war halt dann doch nichts
jaffa kalter aber okay wir sind
eigentlich ganz gut klappt würde ich mal
sagen und können jetzt mal hier aus 320
bis zum nächsten gegner
pablo nieto bist du es hier oben raus
oha das einem megawatt nach oben nagy da
da da da kommen wir sicher nicht mit
einer perle hoch ich sehe es schon
kommen wenn ich jetzt einer perle
werferin klatscht die da oben gegen und
ich will einfach wieder runter dann
willst du da unten
hallo nickel
weinbauer junge was war das für bogen
das ging ja aber wo ich meine ist klar
aber du bist richtig die um es einfach
passt beim wasser ab wie kratzer ja der
war der ist einfach schon wasser gedreht
bergauf bergauf bergauf ich hab' ich
muss jetzt gerade eine vollere was
denken was ich muss gerade was sagen ich
stehe nicht so wenig macht bleibt jetzt
kommt endlich mal zum fight würde ich
sagen mein lieber wo bist du hell oft
erwächst das känguru holla die waldfee
alter weil ich fast nicht gefallen er
ist jetzt bist du wieder unten
ich verstehe nicht ganz ehrlich ich
verstehe den jungen einfach nicht was
geht ab in seinem leben
ich versteh ich verstehen ich wurde
achter trieben herren okay nee nee
einfach nein des da unten oder wobei ich
glaube dass echter und müssen wieder
runter gehen
das war dachte okay erstmal weg hier pam
pam pam brot ganz wichtig für uns jetzt
bitte jetzt nicht so nach dem nächsten
gegner
okay gibt noch zwei leute wir sind
barbara das ist 100 prozentig nutzloses
kit im firefight
das bringt gar nichts richtig spoiler
was dein gegner ist nicht das wird sich
noch früh genug herausstellen und wir
müssen jetzt einfach mal kurz weg rennen
oder weil wir noch wachsen
47 blue cross 47 jahre
bester mann war cool ist wird sich
herausstellen
ich weiß nicht auch scheiße dass die
webseite
ich bin horst ich bin ein vollhorst muss
weiter ist nämlich flugs 7.40 uhr und
morgen nimmt der leute ist ja egal ob du
hättest ihm gut jetzt unkontrollierte
ruhmes geräusche machen so richtig wie
die höhe münchen hätten ab mit mir als
ich den gefallen hat deutlich nach oben
wie immer schreibt bitte in die
kommentare aber es geht ihr moment wie
dem darauf besinnt euch fertig welches
kind in der nächsten folge sehen wollt
schaut es in die kommentare
und dann welches spielen bitte nicht
nochmal weil da habe ich jetzt echt weh
getan damit zweiter höhe gebraucht und
eine gute runde hinzubekommen
heute hat geklappt ich freue mich
trotzdem rüber wie gesagt in die
kommentare schreiben
daumen nach oben möchte das projekt
gefällt und dann sehen wir uns wieder
wenn ihr dennis abgecheckt hatte der
betreiber ist jetzt alles gesagt haut
rein macht gut ich bin der ostsee